Lydia we understand from a tweet that
your film has made over half a million
dollar screening thus far we keep
hearing that theatrical was dead so how
did this
happen well we did something very unique
with our theatrical uh distribution um
we did it on our own and um we have
we've grossed over we're almost at
600,000 but excuse me that's gross
that's uh not our take what essentially
we've done done is we've done one
screening at a time and what we would do
is um our first really big screening
well our first first theatrical
screening was in Ashlin Oregon and we
had been in the film festival there and
we sold out all our screening so we said
okay this is a great Market to go back
clearly people want to see this film and
we were just so amazed with no
advertising really to speak of uh we
stayed they extended us for 6 weeks
and what we do is we usually I usually
try and show up for opening weekend I
come armed with two 500 flyers and ask
everybody to help us spread the word
take 10 flyers and pass them out and so
our our uh method has really been word
of mouth and we really ask people to
help us and and then we also do Outreach
we do um before a film is before the
film is going to be showing in a city
we'll reach out to outdoor stores
churches um any walking groups um yoga
studios and we try and do a lot of
Grassroots Outreach and what we did is
each screening essentially funds the
next one and then the other really
unique thing that we did is um I
financed an RV had it wrapped with our
um our logo and then I did a whole Cross
Country tour I literally went all the
way around the country um and there was
one section two we section that Annie
took on for me thank God because I was
getting pretty tired at that point um
but pretty much we went all the way AC
around the country and I'm thinking
we're guessing that I've probably
appeared somewhere at like a 100
different events um 100 different cities
and done over 200 q&as something some
that number so it's really been about
appearing
and and trying to enlist local people to
help us spread the word and I also think
there's a real desire in our country
right now I've heard somebody refer to
it as spiritual
dehydration a real longing for more
meaning in our lives and to go to a
movie that's uplifting and inspiring
rather than depressing and
disturbing um so I think I think people
are ready for that
do you think that's since the recession
because so many people's lives have been
really uprooted they've had to make
changes you know that probably does have
a pretty big effect and I think too it's
easy to get distracted when you're
you're making money and you're getting
the new toys and you can go shopping and
this and that and then all of a sudden
that's not an option anymore you can't
distract yourself with more buying more
things and um but I think it's also just
the Natural Evolution of our Society I
think little by little we're people are
seeking more meaning and more connection
with each other with our communities and
with the spiritual aspect of ourselves
there's something I'd like to address um
so for me it was really important to
show it in theaters because my intention
in making the film was to bring the
Comino to people so that they could have
a Camino experience just sitting in
their chair it wasn't about trying
trying to inspire everybody to go do the
Camino but it was having everybody at
least get a glimmer or a sliver of the
lessons and of the magic of the Camino
which would Inspire them to do whatever
they're meant to do be it be It Go Walk
The Cino or open a homeless shelter or
spend more time with their
grandchildren and for me seeing it in a
theater was particularly important
because it sort of mimics the Camino
experience you're having this semi
intimate experience with a bunch of
strangers and so and also being on the
big screen you get much more of a sense
of being there of being on the
Camino do you think theatrical
distribution is dead that being said I
know you you wanted that and I agree
that I think that that would lend itself
especially for your film oh I absolutely
do not think theatrical is is dead I
think people really long for that night
out going out and sharing an
experience um maybe it's just a
subconscious desire to share an
experience with people but I really
think there's something very special
about being in that dark room no
interruptions you know the baby's not
crying the dog's not thrown up the
phone's not ringing I mean you're really
there to step into that experience and I
think no matter how big our TVs get
you're not going to have that same
experience at home having found so much
success with the theatrical distribution
what do you think it is that's lent
itself to that aside from having an
amazing film it's very emotional um I
connected very much with all of your
subjects in the film but do you think it
was a snowball effect from other people
talking about it or their own personal
experiences on the Camino and seeing it
I think we were very blessed it was sort
of a perfect storm um in a positive way
because we had a film that
people with this film people can say so
often when you when you walk the Camino
you come home and people are like how
was it and it's like you can't even
begin to talk about it you can't how do
you even start to explain it and this
was one of the reasons I made the film
as well was this way people could say
watch this that's what I went through
now obviously I can't touch on every
experience or every person's but there's
some general themes that everybody that
walks goes through and
I I tried to capture as many of those as
possible and so we had that element so
very frequently people come to see our
film once like somebody that's walked
they'll come and see it once and then
the next night they'll bring three
friends and then two nights later
they'll bring you know their brother and
their sister-in-law and two other people
because they want to be able to share
their Camino experience with people and
um there's just been this huge increase
of interest and um of people Walking the
Camino and so there's a wonderful
organization called American Pilgrims
here in the US and they have separate
Pilgrim chapters all over the country so
we worked very closely with those
chapters um and so they would get all
their friends and they would usually use
it as an event to help people that are
thinking about doing the Camino okay
these are some of the things that you
might encounter if you do the Camino and
so we had we had that going for us we
had the fact that the way had come out
previously so there was literally
thousands of people that had gone and
walked the Camino from when they saw the
way to when our film came out um and
additionally I think that spiritual
dehydration I think people are a lot of
people are really excited about seeing a
film where nothing blows up and nobody
gets murdered I mean you know I'm the
first one I you know I I love my TV
shows and you know kind of esap APAP IST
movies but to a point you know I really
do enjoy something that makes me feel
good